I'm trying to find out what it cost to
get another key for a Honda Pilot there
it is a 2013 Honda Pilot yep that sounds
right was that okay okay thank you do
you need another key for your Honda well
did you know you can skip the car
dealership with the help of TOMS K
company check out how easy this is
before we get started a few important
things first of all you need one working
key that'll start the
engine as long as you can drive the
vehicle with your key you can use Tom's
key company or programming device order
that spare key and be sure the key
Blade's cut our key by photo service
makes that easy while you program it's
important you don't drain your vehicle
battery so keep the radio off don't have
the air conditioning or the heater
running turn the headlights off okay
scan the QR
code and get the app downloaded from the
App Store we're going to fire up the app
pair new key easily program your car key
plug in the programmer come near your
gas and brake pedal look around till you
find the OBD plug and connect it up cuz
it's kind of hard to see what's going on
you can make your life easier by picking
up this optional extension cable with
the cable we can now see what's going on
with our power and communication lights
still on
hold we need to press to scan so we got
to get a some Bluetooth pairing going
there we go we've got pair my key device
and the serial number actually matches
what's on the back so yep we want to
pair that okay it now has this calm
light on so we want to begin
programming okay Enter plate or scan VIN
all right let's see what happens if I
jump out here we can scan the VIN right
here really quick right there we got
it look at that it picked up the VIN
I'll warn you the VIN scan tool is not
ideal you may want to look at your uh
vehicle registration certificate your
insurance card or uh the VIN sticker on
the side of your vehicle and it tells me
it's a 2013 pilot yes that is
correct and here's the new one that
we're going to be programming okay let's
see registration the programmer should
take no longer than 15 minutes do not
navigate out of the app during
programming make sure to have all
previously programmed Keys present and
make sure your cell phone has a strong
cell or Wi-Fi signal okay here we go
let's start programming okay we're
almost up to 100%
oh light just turned off
there light's back on turn the ignition
two clicks to the on position do not
start the engine using our currently
programmed key so here's the working key
that we've
got one
two okay
continue all right turn the ignition off
do not remove the key ignition's off
turn the ignition on again using the
same
key please
wait it's reading the
key turn the ignition
Off remove the key from the ignition and
insert the new key and turn it two
clicks to the on position here's the new
key one
two security light turned on it's
blinking turn the ignition off security
light is blinking on the dashboard turn
the on again using the same
key security light is blinking
again turn the ignition off okay turn it
on
again please wait the security light has
turned off so that's actually looking
really good is the security light off
yes it is off is the security vehicle
security light on or flashing this time
no turn the ignition off do not not
remove the key
okay turn the ignition on using the same
key security light briefly blinked on
and turned off immediately successful
programming please wait your system is
restarting the
procedure okay look at that programming
completed successfully well that's
pretty easy well it's ask if they're
working properly let's unplug everything
and fire up the engine to try
but before that guess how my call to the
Honda dealership is going okay I'm going
on 7 minutes with this phone call still
no answer that's as long as it took me
to make the key here's a new key put it
in security light turned off and it
start up the engine look at that that
was
beautiful let's see if the remote
buttons function okay here we go here's
the old key still works here's a new key
beautiful they both work make sure this
one still
works security light turned off so it's
firing up just
fine excellent it looks like uh par my
ke work beautifully are they working
properly yes why yes they are do we need
any help from the support
team nope I think we're
good I'm pretty impressed that was the
very first time ever trying the par my
my key app and it worked nicely are you
still there sir yeah yeah I sure am okay
because currently the machine that we
use for cutting the keys right now in
service their key cutting machine is
broken well that's a bummer guess what
we got lots of key cutting machines as
you place your order be sure you add our
optional Key by photo key cutting
service just simply snap three photos of
your key recommend turning your key be
sure your phone is directly above so we
get different views of it and we'll cut
cut that keyblade with the magic of our
key by photo key cutting service here's
the key cut with our key by photo
technology isn't that amazing slips
right in and fits
perfectly one thing I want to point out
Honda and Acura Keys like this sometimes
do not want to turn at first
occasionally a key needs a little extra
care before it will fit see the
troubleshooting tip at the end of the
video can you believe how quick and easy
that was with the help of Tom's key
company to make a spare key for this
Honda Pilot well let's find out what the
car dealership is going to charge but
first you might ask a couple questions
well what if something goes wrong guess
what we provide great customer service
just visit help. tomsk key.com where you
can find solutions to lots of common
problems and you can contact our
customer service team if you need
further assistance now if it still
doesn't work no worries we have a full
money back guarantee you just ship
everything back and we refund your money
it's that easy if you've lost all your
keys I'm sorry about that go check out
our all keys lost section where we'll
point you to a company that can come to
you and help you make a spare all right
I'm at 10 minutes now still waiting
hello
hello more hold
music ouch it's hot 13 minutes on hold
is more time than it took me to make the
key yeah yep I'm still here okay 14
minutes so I got the pry okay the key
itself would be around
$16.32 okay and it would need to be
programmed later on for
$189.99 okay so you said 160 plus
189 do you know if there are any ways to
get a get a car key for any less that's
kind of a lot I couldn't tell you I'm my
end to be honest okay all right cool
well thank you so much sure appreciate
it 15 minutes find that out most time
it's an hour to two hours sitting in the
dealership if you've watched this far
will you help me reach my goal of 10,000
subscribers by year end all you have to
do is click that subscribe button down
below and it helps YouTube tell the rest
of the world about the service Toms key
company provides saves people time and
money as of early 2024 did you know
we've saved our customers collectively
over $12 million by skipping the car
dealership to get a spare key for less
money and less time it's pretty amazing
come place your order at tomsk key.com
today where you can get the programmer
car key and with our key by photo
service have it cut so it arrives
already fitting your
vehicle this one's been cut using our
key by photo sometimes you receive the
key and it won't fit in the lock all the
way it can be a real pain so what are
you going to do you can take a file and
just go at it pretty hard cuz if it's
not turning you might as well file it
down really good to see if that gets it
to fit now of course we'll make it right
and we'll cut a new key and send it out
to you but you could avoid waiting for
shipping and save time with this quick
and easy fix that'll often rough it up
up enough that the cut now fits and
slides into the lock nice and smoothly
that's a little tip for Honda and Acura
Vehicles if your key arrives and it
doesn't want to turn at first